let me let me put this one let me just
ask you this
what is the problem with the united
states using
drones for warfare i'll just uh
reference some sues in the
sun soon the art of war he says that a
protracted warfare
is not beneficial to the state and
uh he says that our warfare
is evil inherently but if you have to do
it here's how you do it to win
and we're using drones not to win but to
bring devastation and control over an
area
so in the art of war in that philosophy
what we're doing with drones is
inherently evil
because we're not using them to finish
the war
and win if we are well we're not even in
a war
uh overseas contingency right that's
what they call it
uh my own personal reasons for doing it
is that we are
indiscriminately killing human beings
and celebrating it and then
pretty much destroying whatever moral
fabric or moral law that we are
supposedly fighting for i don't think a
lot of people understand
that drone strikes primarily
kill civilians is that right um it's not
inherent like it's not like they go like
oh this guy's walking his dog we're
gonna [ __ ] kill him no it's not
it's not inherently that it's it's more
like um
they're but by standing in civilians
just as like a as like a consequence of
killing one person who lives in a
building they're gonna kill
it's called they call it collateral
damage and it's a term that they use
to uh marginalize an individual human's
life and just
make them a tally mark um
i saw a lot of a lot of really bad crap
while while i was in and i've only
really talked about my own
experiences and my own my own sin and
shame
but um they would really like if there
was
probably 15 people at a wedding and they
were gonna
they were there to strike too the 15
people
were collateral damage worth getting
those two people
so an example would be if some rambo
character whose job was to go
overseas and go take out
a a terrorist target and this guy
is just going through an entire
apartment building with his
with his automatic weapons just slaying
every every innocent bystander all the
women and children on his way up to the
top floor to find the terrorist
just murdering dozens of people in this
building before he actually gets the
target
this guy would be a war criminal this
guy would be in a prison somewhere
it same like president uh trump just our
former president trump
uh um pardoned four black water
dudes for doing that right they went
into they were basically
in downtown baghdad and we're murdering
people on the street
and that is essentially what
drones do just in an unpersonal
type of way yeah it's a it's a weird
thing where if you just
take us out of it if you remove us from
it
it's this weird thing where it's like
now it's this bridge that we're able to
cross
in a sense it's um you know there's
i i talk a lot about warrior culture and
warrior philosophy
um because i grew i grew up in a family
of wrestlers
right so like from the moment that i
could
pretty much walk i was on or around the
wrestling
and in wrestling you face your opponent
you know you work hard
you train you understand your body and
how you move
and maybe study the enemies movement so
that you can beat them
with drones there's no facing your enemy
there's just
you're basically taking people who are
incapable of
of operating on that level of
physicality
and giving them the ability to glorify
war
in a way that makes them feel like
they're participating i
kind of feel like it's a lot like the q
anon conspiracy crap
where um people want to feel involved
and like they're doing um something for
the greater good or they're they're part
of a
a movement but really all it is is just
indiscriminate violence
now the argument against this
would be we're doing this to keep people
safe here in america
right right our or boots off off the
ground that's another one
what do you say to that argument i say
that uh you we devalue
the people that are part of the warrior
class
that dedicate themselves to
sacrificing their life for a noble cause
right um in the spiritual
world um of the warrior it would
they would talk about how even if you
are a noble and good warrior and you're
fighting an
in noble cause what you're doing is is a
sin
and so we're taking people who
um let's say let's compare uh drones to
a sniper
right a sniper's in country they're
sitting there with their partner they're
monitoring they're sometimes sitting
laying down for days at a time without
moving right
takes a whole bunch of concentration and
skill
like years of training
well you're putting those
that same kind of power within the drone
operators but you're taking
young men and women out of high school
and giving them the power without the
training
and glorifying something that doesn't
deserve to be glorified
now isn't another thing that like we
just we tell
people going to war going off to fight
wars that they're fighting for a noble
cause they're fighting for
freedom but but
in these regime change world in these
regime change wars and
in the history of our wars
they have always been for the
acquisition
of something for the acquisition of oil
or
or whatever it might be but we tell
these people we tell
our our military our warriors they
believe that they're fighting for a
noble cause they believe that they're
fighting for freedom
or for peace um have you ever read
uh lieutenant colonel david grossman's
on war and on killing no
so he's got two books on war on killing
and on killing is probably my favorite
of the two
because it talks about the psychological
cost of killing in warfare
and throughout history um
the idea of fighting for a noble cause
is given to every group of soldiers that
that fight
even though we can see through our own
lens now that usually that
most people die in very painful way
people cry out for their mothers but
what he says in
on killing is that we we have to glorify
it the soldier has to glorify
and and say what he's doing is good in
order for him to get past
the barriers that prevent him from
actually taking the steps necessary
um the term that is used is drinking
from the waters of the river lethe
which is in greek mythology
when you're dead you have to cross the
river left a
and it erases all the memories from your
past
so that you can be reborn again and mars
or ares the god of war gives a cup
of the river of lethe to each of the
warriors that
fight you know so we forget the lessons
of of history um and our society or
we're not even taught it
and so we must so so
you know we have to
soldiers see their friend uh friends and
and
and brothers and and people die and they
have to say that there's a reason for it
you know
people who lose family in in the war
time they have to say well
my son or my brother sister
mother or father sacrificed their life
for a noble cause
and it makes them feel better about
the loss the death right and
without that aspect of it people would
be
in despair and people would be up in
arms and righteously they should be up
in arms because
if we look at the last 20 years what
have we accomplished
at all if our when our with our
conflicts over in the middle east and
africa
um where we've just destabilized the
world even more
for what purpose they want to get rid of
iran
because of uh you know some sort of
control over monetary value of something
it's it's complete greed you know we're
not fighting for a noble cause we're not
fighting an enemy
you know there was a guy who was trained
by the cia
who flew plain who got men to fly planes
into you know places
in the united states it wasn't a group
of people
who an entire culture it wasn't a
specific country
it was a person trained by the united
states
military united states organizations and
institutions
that eventually turned on the united
states and
uh started this whole conflict um
you know if we look at like what
happened right before 9 11. the day
before 9 11 happened
um uh i think it was colin powell was
uh getting on msnbc and talking about
how there's trillions of dollars that
are unaccounted for at the pentagon and
all of a sudden 9 11 happened
if we look at halliburton and cheyney
they've made trillions of dollars off
this war
and we see that our country is in
severe debt you know our people are in
poverty
it's hard to get health care it's hard
to get food it's hard to get shelter
so we've really just destroyed our
entire culture for
uh an emotional reason rather than a
logical
reason or even a spiritual reason like
when um
my when i first joined the military uh
i didn't do so to kill i joined under
the intelligence program
i did so because i was gonna get four
four to six years get my education get
out
i didn't intend to join the drone
program i just scored high enough that
they just shoved me into it
um but when i was joining the military i
asked
my family where they watched fox news
they were they're they're the typical
republican christians that
uh don't even think for themselves but
uh they were saying that we need to go
over there we need to destroy
the enemies of god and all that type of
stuff but when i actually
joined they were like oh you're gonna go
overseas and get killed like we don't
want you to do that so
they were willing to send other people
to die
but when it came to a personal sacrifice
that ideal was put in jeopardy
and then once i actually went to the
experience and came out and started
talking to my family
i was wrong because i was no longer
in agreement with the right ideology
they still think that we need to be over
there and
unfortunately the christians that i know
still think that we need to be over
there killing muslims because they're
the enemies of god
we're not over there for anything else
you know well where's the oil where's
the resources coming back here where's
you know where's the democracy that we
went to go
stabilize you know even if we look at
the kurds who saddam hussein was
genociding burying in mass graves
we we went over there and as soon as
they're free they're going up and north
into turkey north of missoula
and then we're using our own drones to
help kill them
with the turkish military so we've
betrayed our own
our own allies they're basically our
only
i